[Music]
welcome to the iron Lords podcast
[Music]
and who is this five gentleman we have
in the realm of cash West today I'm uh
the creative director
creative director of living so let's
just start off the back why is it three
of that too that's a great question
um so a half the team wanted to do or
name the game goes in it or two and the
other half goes later for two compromise
then
someone would make a floor yeah and then
we weren't allowed to so yeah very
unconventional team let's get right into
it
gold simulator now the first thing I
remember seeing this game at an early
like e-through show and I'm like this is
the wildest concept I've ever seen so
for people who are living under a rock
and have no idea what Goat Simulator is
please tell the people what this game
and we're trying to capture one of them
is
the high-end version of that is the
high-end yeah we've really even done our
research on Google
so the game is basically just a big
sandbox it's a huge open world and we're
trying to pack in the content every
looking chronic should be something like
a quest or pick up or just craziness to
do and uh and it's just
a fun fact so what did you what did you
learn coming from the original gold
slimulator so now obviously the game did
well the president put a lot of people
yeah you got this rambunctious code I
mean I don't get tear around with
everybody so what did you learn from the
first experience first game and like
decided
four-player and also switch
running around in the same road in the
same craziness
split screen seems to be a thing yeah
that's hilarious so our philosophy is
that little player just enhanced
yeah
it's really been it's proven itself over
and over that it is
so four player online then again now
they as far as like Cooperative
progression they joined up
I'm dying right now you can grind it
I'm done we are grinding phone calls
with a rocket attack does that this is
wow this is wild right here
and then we got instinct tell us about
the Instinct do the triple jump finish
what's this about yeah so instances
basically running around in the sandbox
and you're kind of like lost or unsure
what to do you always have these
challenges you do and some of them are
just show what types of mechanics there
are in the world but also some specific
area specific challenges if you reach
the highest point in this area
and then we also have uh so this is
an apartment
is
so you can go you can start like doing
tricks
YouTube
like a third place but then I can also
just go here and I can shoot if I want
to press press the button yeah yeah and
let's take the other green
first place the second place
have fun try it out there we go I got
first place and I got a crown I enjoyed
Adam no you can't this is hilarious this
is a this is a permanent gear unlock now
that you've done this exactly
this is also a new system that we've
revamped in so you have seven different
slots to customize you customize the
type of goat so you can be a tasty goat
tacos or a Tony Shark oh it's only sharp
okay that was nice nice change your head
here
and it's just the tons of just wacky
stuff wait wait go hold on what's the
feather way
does the goat lift bro yeah does the
goat live and then there's enough
like this one is
try that one out
we have a little vortex
one thing that is really cool is the
sandbox element in the environment all
you guys are able to interact wow that
is pretty impressive all of the products
in the future compiling in one spot in
this open sandbox like I was charging
was it that for the team to kind of get
back on that looks really complex yeah
and single player it's uh it's
incredibly straightforward when adding
the most of an online multiplayer it's
that's a whole other like systems yeah
it didn't print hectic to figure that
out because we're not like gating people
all four players can be in different
places in the map and that needs to also
work wait a minute all four players
different places
that was our like we wanted players to
there's a pretty big map so it was kind
of crazy someone can be here doing
something right here everywhere we've
added some systems to help help players
be together you can teleport to the math
form like if someone finds an offense or
something
but we don't want to gay people and
that's awesome that is really awesome
because again you know I'm coming from a
lot of foreplay Cooperative games that
as much as I love them there's usually
sometimes of a Feather mechanic yeah
well you can't get outside of a certain
boundary but allowing people to still
doom and play to how they want
individually and come together so as far
as the coming together aspect is it like
some forms of trusting how would you
what are the things to kind of pull
players to play together what would be
somebody incentives
the question is if you find a question
everybody gets a notification
coin got it then there's also
um
so we have seven different mini games to
choose from
[Music]
these are for example Google
we've put out some places where it's
like designed and it feels good right
but then we unlock the immediately
let's start them wherever you want oh
that's pretty cool and I'm assuming some
have like that competitive aspects
exactly and those are PVP mode
nice nice that is really cool and then
the third part is we have two towers and
those are the overall progression system
that we have here
let's go check that out
and the game looks absolutely phenomenal
I'm gonna assume unreal
and more information of
okay events will pop up and there's
something we'll see so almost Assassin's
Creed like in a sense that like you're
going up and then you're kind of
unlocking this area more things in this
area yeah got it yeah there's a meeting
those are only multiplayer specifically
second place incomplete
again and now we can answer our super
good Society
no Illuminati with the goats
don't forget scammed to see if you're
available
this is true behind the scenes actually
you're getting to see we're gonna see
really what's going on with the ghosts
so this is basically this door is your
energy progression
everything you do in the sandbox you'll
gain what we call like I said really
Illuminati points foreign
actually kind of like bring back
everybody together and experience this
is awesome
this looks really cool absolutely
hilarious I love the collaborative
aspect engine looks absolutely
phenomenal now as far as development how
long have we been in development and how
close
for five years
an hour through the years we've grown to
an hour almost 30. wow
and releases November 17th
um
Xbox series XMS okay here we go look man
this looks phenomenal I love that it
doesn't take it so it sounds seriously
it has the spirit of the first I just
have a final question like how proud is
the team to see the reception of how you
got started to like goat simulator three
technically two what is that it's been
it's been a World ride to see uh people
find the game it has on it and kind of
pushing
okay instead of just like pushing what
what Johnson is
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]